and it was 5 years ago today December 4th 2018 the
NHL Board of Governors granted an expansion team
to Seattle so history team could fit in well
today as a quick shot by G is knocked aside
by Samuel Mar B now it's pulled out five y strand
lost it Barett will carry it out to Center Baron
in on the attack trying to get around it's done SP
it back of the goal kicks it front and it's taken
away by P play it up for Yanni gour Quick Pass yor
strand steps it on net and it's into the glove of
mono here's Dar with a shot towards the kicks
off the boards quickly andar had to be careful
there Mitchell steving after it right it across
here's AR the chance SC out of the save and G
will move it up for borr it after him and Poes it
P Alex has got it turned over Anderson and on hand
scores sha mahad snaps a 14-game goal is drown
of the Canadian strike first who haven't scored
in a while and Anderson has been the longest he
hasn't scored yet but in the last two games in
Detroit the other night on the Lindstrom goal and
here he could have shot but elected to go to the
sure thing Lindstrom scored and so did Monahan
as he's sitting all the way on the right of gr
bow when you go in behind the net as a defenseman
with your opponent and he comes out one side you
come out the other that's a bad sign first goal
altoe with celd now going after it thinking his
stick on it Cartier well H it off for veneer stop
Caufield will grab it takes the shot it was a weak
one grow blocked it got his sticking away M holds
the line again caught up Anders Caufield weight
shoots hit the post and it goes out of play revans
he cranks that off the crossbar and then that's a
nasty turnover everyone's leaving the zone and
the Canadians turn around and Coffield looks
to go short side straight upstairs AR tried to
FP it to the net MC Gallagher going there and
take it away and lenberg will lead it back for
Seattle knocked off his kick gun follows sh for
the shot MBO the save oh and a great save on the
rebound by monbo kicking out the pad off lber at
the ring first monbo on just dshot and wber comes
right in the left pad comes out again Gallagher
bringing it in put the pass in the skates of done
NOA Sage back in the net for Pearson centered in
front the morak takes the whack out kick to it
right a ATT grow the stop off Pearson monbo and
then this one comes out in front and grow gets his
left leg against the post and then out the other
side comes Pearson and he comes right across
and gets the right pad there to they'll fire
it back in then he was knocked over by P gallager
and front just TI It Wide Bon Gallagher looks it
across for dorak for Jaden strubel hands
it off for dorak bodies it front Pearson
sces
first and 20 games for Tanner Pearson as he
knocks home the rebound to make it two nothing
it's been since October 23rd since he's found
the mesh and much for all with guys in front
of the net that's one thing that they were
a little void of in the Detroit game where
they had pucks going to the net but they really
didn't have enough action in front of Uso and
then tonight they have been All Around the Net
nice play by struble over to Dvorak it's not a
hard Slap Shot there's not a big back scratcher
he just gets it to the net because they have
traffic there X Su to Cole Coffield Coffield
waiting with it down in TI Suzuki can't get
to the front of the neet Coffield has got it
Suzuki in front scores Mahan second out the
night and it's the first Power Play goal
scored against the kren for the Montreal
Canadians that's what you're trying to do watch
91 he's going to move up to the high slot in the
bumper Zone Monahan Suzuki's going to move down
to the goal line what they're doing is they're
trying to make the penalty Killers make choices
where do you go to shut down the scene and then
as soon as you make the adjustment two quick
plays Coffield Suzuki Monahan red light there
you go down up it back for Larson Larson gives
it up for Dunn Dunn to M waiting shoot scores
Jared mccan puts it home after a ship that's
just under 3 minutes long for the Canadians
and Seattle on the board well you could see it
coming and good job by the crack guys whose gas
tanks were empty there was nothing left and
the one thing you couldn't do was lose the
draw clean and deor act it and not only did
he lose the draw clean ma lost his stick in
a scramble in the boards so now you got tired
guys a guy with no stick and there's mat who
was on mccan he doesn't have to stick to get to
the puck and mccan takes advantage of that on
hand chopped it up for emans now Josh Anderson
with it Anderson checks up shoots grar the save
with a minute and 25 to go in the first period a
little spinorama in the middle tried to go five
ho Yamamoto and on the wing taken to the boards
bers forgun he'll fire mono the save Tolman in
on it back to G shoots scores it's stun rips it
home under the bar it's in and out in a hurry
and a power play goal has the Kraken within one
well off the first shot from Dunn I thought tol
and just should have stepped in and one Ed the
second one and instead he fears it back to Dun
his numbers have been this year in a in the
span of a year and there's the one I thought
tolin and should have stepped into and Let It
Rip but he didn't went back to Dunn and then
dun goes high on the stick side this is going
to hit the back of the net and came straight
down referee was right there made the signal for
the goal right away this is a heater a high hard
one going straight up and the Kraken did exactly
what they should do when you get an opportunity
and especially a team like Montreal here's lovsky
going to the N trying to get his stick free and he
was C by Larson and looking for a call celd
Batson on that crear with the sa sovi go go
after the loose pck thought that was just good
solid defensive play and then getting the puck
back in the slot and cough goes for another
esape takes the shot it's blocked by Belmar
deor chases it down plays it back in the N for
Gallagher in front chance right off Pearson two
WS out of crew with the saveal down low below
the goal line Gallagher he's going to try to
just set this out in the front to Pearson and he
does a good job of it because he lands it right
on his stick now it gets to the toe of his blade
so he really doesn't get as high as he wants but
he hands it off for mat up the wing celd tipped
it out Suzuki has lowski going to the m Suzuki
shoots through the save rebound put the back and
fr and upar couldn't B it off of an in Suzuki and
slavoski 21 one I like the fact Suzuki takes the
shot look at the presence of mine to try to bank
it back off grow round the boards and Jordan
Everly is on it Coffield good stick to break
it up Schulz forced back inside his own line up
ahead for Manan TI it in off the board and he
fires Mar B squeezes it and holds on and Schultz
is going to step up and throw this to macam but
he misses him it comes off the back wall and
it's just not enough time for mono to kind of
get the lay of the land and that's a really
good opportunity Anderson trying to pressure
him now it's Everly looks to center it goes off
escape toing and the done shooting M the same
rebound pu still loose and it's picked up by Josh
Anderson he'll put it down the ice and he scores
goal from the Canadians he's going to really
put the pressure on the wall when the puck
goes up the wall he goes down to help out and
then and the Montreal Canadians with a big
win and you know again I I think Maro made
some really good saves here in this one as
well